[Music]
be and Ben they're absolutely hating
each other they had a disastrous first
date that they both can't really forget
about I couldn't get her out of here
fast enough and then they meet years
later at this wedding they're caught off
guard when they see each other it does
not go smoothly at all four words
animosity hate liar five words no just
shut the up but didn't they have to
work together cuz my parents want me to
go back with my ex and he wants to go
with another girl so they team up
they're like okay we're going to fake it
and it ends up being a disaster
permission to put my left hand when your
right but granted not in circles it's
not a magic lamp now you're just playing
bit